c'est vrai qu'à fida
il était triste de ce qu'a dit laurent
sur toi
c'est passager très affecté je voulais
pas venir ils savaient que j'avais
beaucoup de considération et d'affection
pour guillaume frisquet qui est un vrai
producteur avec qui j'ai travaillé et
mathieu aidant les mets donc voila et
avec qui j'ai fait confiance et m'ont
appelé à dallas minutes j'ai joué le jeu
pas pour remplir le théâtre parce que ça
serait quelque chose quelqu'un qui va
droit au but j'aurais préféré faire
l'émission audible de théâtre il s'avère
que c'est plein grâce à un solo ring
depuis vingt ans et j'ai trouvé ça très
dur d'arriver sur un plateau et de se
faire humilier
d'avoir eu des propos en parlant d'une
femme enfin les femmes les droits les
gens se battent les femmes se battent
depuis 50 ans non mais on dit pas
qu'elle ait salo mélo nous alors on
essaie cesser sa décision j'ai trouvé ça
très dur surtout que depuis depuis
presque quatre semaines on est on est
plein et en plus en guise de conclusion
vous avez fait un record d'audience sur
douze minutes où j'étais là et ça me
mine ça ça mérite un minimum de respect
alors
alors laurent laurent est ce qu est ce
que je savais qu'elle allait venir un
fida ou pas assez généreuse dire
séparions papier moi non plus je
ne savais pas que j'allais dire là je
savais pas que tu es là oui même si je
savais pas je savais pas je je pensais
faire de la promo un truc sympathique en
parlant du théâtre et j'arrive là tout
le temps c'est toujours les peaux de
banane quoi un épisode de voltage ya
cinq ans mais on va pas montrer le faust
ou les concerts en germanie qui sont
ceux-là qui a toujours un sabotage quand
vous venez d'un milieu défavorisé et je
trouve ça à un moment donné il y en a
marre il y en a vraiment marre surtout
qu'en plus je sauve la ministre que
chaque fois je fais un report d'audience
c'est même là et ça mérite un minimum de
respect a consacré
c'est vrai qu'on commence à beaucoup
bien s'aimer ah bah tiens
là je vois pas le rapport entre le
milieu social et ce qu'on a dit
m avec tout le respect que je dois j'ai
pas envie de rentrer dans des polémiques
et thomas scott est un ami je t'aime
bien pas moi moi tu m'as bien reçue
c'est pas ça le problème c'est à dire en
fait que j'étais très affecté par les
propos des légers envers moi et
également envers la femme papara par en
plus monsieur quand même plus de 58 ans
qui vient quand même d'un milieu il a
fait des études fois c'est quand même
pas le je me suis dit mais pourquoi
pourquoi il dit je suis sale c'est comme
si en fait c'était une histoire de
couleur ça les chaînes on attendait les
soit terminé parce que c'est quand même
moi qui t'ai laurent épater les les
choses on dit pas une femme vous n'êtes
pas si mam simone veil voyez alors voilà
donc vous rentrer dans des choses en
parlant de la femme une femme qu'elle a
envie d'être en jean une robe peu
importe elle sait ce qu on dit pas ça
une femme
n'a duré
qu'un petit la raison et à fille d'alors
laurent votre réponse et est tombé j'ai
pas donné et le est également la chose
qui m'a également affecté je n'ai pas du
tout aimé la mer vous avez parlé de
bigard qui est un mec comme moi qui est
un ouvrier qui sonne ouais qu'ils n'ont
pas été entendus si je m'étais s'est
battue qui sort également d'un milieu
100 millions d'ouvriers ses parents et
des sharks chez moi j'ai fait des
artistes on met plus un mec génial et
j'ai pas du tout aimé damien on vous
avait parlé de sa femme sa vie privée je
pense que vous n'aimeriez pas également
qu'on parle de votre vie privée j'ai
presque jaloux j'ai presque trouvé que
c'était diffamatoires et est presque
haineux et très méchant actually laurent
hallé en or blanc alors déjà l'eau
les gens va régler en deux secondes il
est pas là pour répondre c'est pas moi
qui ai parlé sa vie privée c'était un
commentaire qu'on faisait sur le la
bigard sa femme qui disait que ils
étaient un couple libre et mathieu nous
fait réagir je dis que quand on parle
des bigard généralement soit pour des
scandales soit pour du sud de cul donc
j'ai pas grand chose à faire dans
l'absolu c'est tout ce que j'ai même pas
ce que j'ai voulu être là à la réunion
d'hier est le devenir parce que tu m'as
mettra la prochaine je vais dire qu'au
début alors te trouve bien plus dosée
aujourd'hui est bien plus intéressante
pourparlers échouent qu'on peut échanger
c'est dommage bien évidemment passerez
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
ya du temps mais moi on dirait qu'on me
la nar on dirait qu'on peut pas blâmer